thank you  good afternoon and thanks for joining us  here at noon I'm Vanessa Murphy we start  with breaking news the head of the  Department of Corrections stepping down  after one of the latest failures inside  Nevada prisons Governor Steve sisalak  announcing director Charles Daniels is  resigning at his request this is after a  five-day Manhunt for a convicted  murderer who escaped from the southern  desert Correctional Center governor  sisalak also announcing six officers are  placed on administrative leave and an  investigation will take place into the  security breach and how no one seemed to  notice the inmate was missing for four  days the Escape is just the latest in a  series of events the 8 news now  investigators have exposed we'll have  more on this story today at 4 5 and 6.